so joining an MCU movie is not like
signing on for any other movies so I was
wondering what did you find to be the
most surprising part about joining this
whirlwind that is basically one of the
most epic franchises out there ah you
you don't expect to sit on set and go
like how can I be a Marvel fan and an
employee at the same time that's quite
that's weird right
this is where I um I would I just kind
of you Roadrunner through it because you
just have so much to do and then you
take a moment and look around a new life
this is a whole world a whole world that
I've never got insight to before and now
I get to be one of those people who get
to see it all so and actually being a
part of it didn't take the magic away
like I just saw all of the like
construction of it all and it was just
really beautiful to see the creation and
but yeah it was magical was there
anything about the production part that
made you go oh that's how they do it
yeah
make up make up when you see people in
their costumes that they're not like
fully unconscious so they'll like have a
head on but they won't they'll have like
their normal hands
I never seen been a lot of the time
around set like he was just like half
and half like he had his trousers on and
like his shoes but then he would have
that top half as him that's other than
the Cat in the Hat the other thing I
repeat from that set visit is we beasts
crawlin and yeah that has even more
meaning to me after watching this movie
for some reason you don't know why but
it does right yeah we be scrolling they
see me scrolling as well and with jamon
Ben is like Ben is basically a jukebox
he's like a jukebox of all generations
he's maybe really nice iTunes play this
section anyway yeah yeah he's cool like
that he really is one of the coolest
people I've ever hands down hands down
one of the coolest parts about this
movie though is the friendship between
you and brie Larson there's just so much
chemistry there and we don't really have
any female friendships quite like that
quite like that closest sisters vibe
that we see in this movie so was that
kind of on your
mind going into this June Bri talk about
that at all I feel like we we didn't
need to like have deep discussions about
it because maybe telepathically we knew
what we wanted to represent we both have
really good friends in our lives so we
just wanted to like take that and just
like plop it into the screen and so it
never felt like hard work it always felt
really easy and she's just a cool chick
so it's easy to just get along with her
and be like let's create this and then
we see it on screen like yeah we just we
did that because we were just having a
good time um so yeah it was just really
easy and quite free-flowing did Acura
fit into that vibe very well because she
just pops big-time as Monica I loved her
in this me too me too she is a girl that
just gets it she just knew exactly what
she was doing day one and said she just
came with her energy everyone loved her
she had there's some really nice moments
that she brings in the movie actually
that is quite special because you can
see just how she's been raised as a Kyra
and you can see just how Monica has been
raised by Maria so it feels like she has
like a grounding and an intelligence and
the maturity to her that really
represents young people well I think
we've got a new generation coming up who
were just clued up man this movie's
gonna make a big difference for a lot of
people out there ISIF included the most
important question I have to ask you
right now though is tell me something so
bizarre about yourself that a scroll
couldn't even come up with it good
question I have um a line of three
beauty spots somewhere ah on me like
like constellations like okay I could
almost like you know like you get stars
into the sky it's like three big spots
and my best friend has the same beauty
spots in the same place that is meant to
be right there I've just removed
saranghae i love it
you